[Música]
directo Ah aquí en France 24 hoy nos
vamos hasta Perú con nuestro
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
esta tarde se conoció la noticia de la
liberación de los entornos a 150
turistas que permanecían retenidos desde
el jueves por indígenas que protestaban
por el derrame de crudo en un oleoducto
los hechos se han producido en torno al
río marañón en la región amazónica de
leto Qué pasó en concreto con el derrame
de petróleo y que exigen los
manifestantes Francisco
Buenas noches Rodrigo pobladores de 8
comunidades indígenas bloqueaban desde
el pasado miércoles el tránsito de
embarcaciones en el río marañón para
exigirle al gobierno del presidente
Castillo una solución inmediata ante el
derrame petróleo que se habría producido
el 16 de septiembre en la quebrada de
cuni Nico al respecto el líder indígena
Watson Trujillo señaló que en la zona
existen constantes derrames de la
empresa Estatal de petróleo Petro Perú y
tanto el gobierno como el congreso no
toman una atención a sus urgentes
necesidades de remediación ambiental
agua potable alimentación y salud por su
parte el Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres
ha señalado de que el estado peruano sí
está atendiendo a la emergencia
ambiental y responsabilizó algunos
comuneros de estar haciendo ataques a lo
leducto según el Primer Ministro Torres
serían algunos comuneros que hacen te
saludo para luego pedir remediación
ambiental e indemnizaciones y es en esa
línea que la empresa Petro Perú ha
anunciado a través de un comunicado que
desde diciembre pasado vienen sufriendo
11 ataques aleluyaducto con 46 cortes
intencionales bueno Francisco qué
razones se dieron por tanto para la
liberación y que se espera que pase
ahora tanto por parte de los
manifestantes como de las autoridades
bueno acá tuvo que intervenir la
defensoría del pueblo de Perú que
intermedio con los líderes indígenas y
prometió buscar una solución los más de
150 turistas fueron liberados pero los
indígenas dieron un ultimátum de 10 días
al presidente Pedro Castillo para que
forme una comisión multisectorial de
alto nivel y busquen soluciones ante
este tema o de lo contrario anunciando
que van a tomar medidas radicales de
protesta por su parte la defensoría del
pueblo ha pedido a las autoridades una
investigación para esclarecer esta
situación Mientras tanto el congreso de
Perú está preparando una comisión
investigadora donde va a citar a la
ministra de energía y Minas Alejandra
Herrera así como a alto funcionarios de
Petro Perú para que se esclarezca este
tema que para todos está confuso y
enredado